this is the first store we got it's kind
of is it interesting and weird story
from Politico Gomer's suit May Force
Pence's hand in effort to overturn
Trump's defeat the vice president is set
to oversee certification of Biden's
electoral college women I've been
reading a lot about the powers that Mike
Pence has
and of course you've got Trump
supporters saying Mike Pence is
basically the judge with the gavel and
he decides but then you've got the left
saying he's basically just like the
clerk handing out you know tickets you
hand him the envelopes and he goes to
the mail room and he just passes out the
things to the office well that's right
and see what's going on they say rep
Louis Gomer Republican of Texas and
Donald Trump's uh and president Donald
Trump's defeated electors from Arizona
May Force vice president Mike Pence to
publicly pick a side in Trump's bid to
overturn his election loss Gomer did a
handful of would-be electors sued pence
in federal court on Monday and a long
shot bid to throw out the rules that
govern congress's counting of electoral
votes next week it's an effort they hope
will permit Pence who is tasked with
leading the January 6th session of the
House and Senate to Simply ignore
president-elect Joe Biden's electors and
count Trump's losing slates instead the
lawsuit asserts of the 1887 law known as
The Electoral count act the vague
statute that has long governed the
electoral vote counting process with
minimal drama unconstitutionally binds
pence from exercising total authority to
choose which votes to count saying quote
under the 12th Amendment defendant Pence
alone has the exclusive Authority and
sole discretion to open and permit the
counting of the electoral votes of for a
given State and where there are
competing slates of electors or where
there is objection to any single slate
of electors to determine which electors
votes or whether None Shall be counted
the suit contends the lawsuit comes
before comes before judge Jeremy
kernodle a trump appointee to the U.S
District Court of the eastern district
of Texas it's unclear if he'll Grant the
request for an expedited judgment though
the law itself is unlikely to gain legal
traction it does put pence in the
position of having to either contest the
suit putting on the opposite side of the
Trump and the GOP Defenders or support
it and lay bare the intention to subvert
the will of the voters in the 2020
election they say pants is engaged with
GOP lawmakers seeking to reverse the
election results but is avoided publicly
taking a side in the matter I think
that's actually not true I don't know if
you guys saw Pence's speech where he
said we're not going to stop fighting
until every legal vote is counted and
every illegal vote you know is not
counted I think Mike Pence is leaning
towards at least in a public sense you
know I'm going to support Trump but I
got to tell you man
here's my bet January 6 comes around
they I don't you guys you guys all
probably know they did that uh the
Electoral candidates for the Republicans
cast their procedural votes I bet Mike
Pence is going to be like Joe Biden wins
bang the hammer and we're done
that is probably likely to be completely
honest look they're they're flailing
right now and I it's like you're either
with us or you're against us I mean
we've been dealing with this over over
at Blaze and it doesn't stop just at the
Glenn Beck level it goes all the way up
to Mike Pence where they won Allegiance
and uh you the lines being drawn in the
sand so either you with us or are you
against us and that's more so what it is
and to to be fair when we talk about
this whole not just with this election
really courts in general it's all
posturing to really Force the hand
um of folks to really force them to take
aside publicly or not because generally
it's just gonna fall dead anyway so and
they know that they're not they're not
stupid it's a matter of like he kind of
mentioned it's like it's about a matter
of forcing
um him publicly to to take a stance but
that's been the approach really and
they're getting more and more aggressive
and it's like we we want to know who's
with us are you with us are you not they
they ignore one thing in this political
article Politico article pens could just
ignore it yeah and it goes to court and
they make up goes
I don't I think he's he's traditional
he's he's very much more establishment
well if you look at Pence and Trump
especially after election day you see
Pence always sticking more to the
establishment you could see him
contradict Donald Trump in many
instances not just regarding this issue
but also the vaccine issue specifically
Donald Trump even getting rid of a
directive saying that the top White
House staff was going to be vaccinated
he got rid of that and Mike Pence was
the only one who went out on national
television and said I'm going to get you
know vaccinated so that was a clear
differential of opinions and we've seen
them on both sides of the issues a lot
of different times this is why I think
they're doing the lawsuit because there
was another story apparently in a bunch
of the emails Trump was sending out it
no longer says Trump Pence it just says
Trump yeah so so leftists were like
Pence is out and this was a couple weeks
ago so I think this is why you've got
some Republicans saying Mike Pence
because we want they want to know now
but Pence was at that meeting at the
White House when I think it was I can't
remember I think it was Pennsylvania's
electors showed up and had a meeting
with Trump and apparently they're like
hardcore in it for Trump they're trying
a bunch of different states have been
like demanding the governors give
special sessions for their state you
know state congress or whatever General
assemblies so that they can officially
certify electors for Trump
yeah like look
this I think it's going to ramp up I
mean we talk about the six but I think
it's going to go really further than
that the GOP right now is in it it may
be blowing up like it sounds silly to
say that but seriously like it may be
blowing up and and whether you think
that's on Trump or his supporters that's
neither here nor there right now you're
seeing lines in the sand be drawn and a
lot of folks don't want to go down with
that chip especially the establishment
types because they look at it as it's
not necessarily the whole threat to the
democracy
government especially at the federal
level has its way of going about things
right and it's been done this way for a
very long time and they want it to
remain as such and of course Trump is
kind of the nuke uh in that where he he
kind of blows things up and a lot of
folks don't yeah it's cool to support
them everybody was on on the same page
with them for the last four years but
then they see it going this route
definitely post post election or you
know post let's say November and a lot
of folks don't want to go down with that
chip so you're going to see them kind of
be shaky about definitely these big Uber
public uh Geo peers they're not going to
be like all in like that they kind of
gotta teeter-totter if you will well the
battle lines are drawn and people are
making their decisions and you could see
it with major establishment figures like
Rupert Murdoch especially with his news
Publications where he stands and where
some of the trumpers and never Trumper
stands and uh it's it's it's a big
fragmentation of the whole GOP party
that we're seeing right now yeah check
this out check us out we got this uh the
New York Post cover cover says stop Mr
President stop the insanity you lost the
election here's how to save your legacy
Trump supporters don't care about that
no no Trump supporters are willing to
support news outlets that support them
and then as soon as you say okay now
here's where we push back as they get
out we don't care if you're not if you
don't got our back anymore we're done
with you I think they underestimate how
many people support the the man for the
man like their allegiance isn't to the
GOP their allegiance is to him and I
think a lot of people underestimate that
so you know we're going to see what what
happens but this is why it's been drawn
and it's been interesting to see how I
think after the initial election like
you know I was we were covering this
over at the Blaze the election everybody
kind of had their their way of going
about things and I know it's the further
we got away from it the more folks are
like okay maybe it's an ill that we just
have to hold I don't know if it's a
rather about saving face or again it's
it's a certain way that things have been
done the establishment or whatever you
want to call them whether you think
Trump is a part of it I don't know I I
really don't care nonetheless you know
that there is is a fight being had right
now yeah and it's I think it's a lot
bigger than what the people are talking
about and I think both sides are not
doing themselves any favors I mean you
got the establishment side and you
literally have the cyber security Chief
coming out and saying one day that we
had the most secure election in American
history and then a couple days later
finding out the entire government was
hacked the worst the Cyber Pearl Harbor
digital Pearl Harbor the digital Pearl
Harbor I mean come on how does that make
sense the two I mean there hasn't been a
mainstream media journalist that
connected this the two and went to him
and asked him a legitimate question
about this but also Donald Trump is not
doing himself any favors by signing this
900 billion dollar spending Bill and
giving gender studies to Pakistan and
speed boats to Sri Lanka meanwhile
everyone else here is having a hard time
even just what kind of speed boats
why does Sri Lanka need speed boats I
mean why does Pakistan need gender
programs yes I understand 10 million
dollars not the biggest thing in this
bill but I'd rather just I'd rather we
just gave 10 million dollars to a random
American like here you go just here's
here's the money have a nice day but you
can really see it man that the Geo so so
here's what I want to say I think I did
a segment on this earlier today I think
the Republicans are probably on track to
win in Georgia so this is this I'm
flipping from my earlier stance I said
before I thought the Democrats were
going to win because uh Donald Trump's
not on the ticket but with the polls
that have been coming out and there's a
bunch they show that it's a neck and
neck race and the polls were all off
underestimating Republicans so it looks
like it's going to be and I'm just
saying based off of that metric the
Republicans are probably actually going
to win in Georgia and a lot of people
thought so but I do think it's fair to
point out
people in Georgia who support Trump
have a road trip to make that day on
January 5th instead of going and voting
they got to pack up the car and head to
DC because January 6th is the big
support the president day so I'll tell
you if you ask a lot a lot of these
Trump supporters who might actually go
out and vote because Trump's going to
Rally there and he asks them to they
might still you know say thank you for
coming Trump and thanks for the rally
but if I have to choose between voting
for these people or supporting you in DC
I'm going to DC do they have mail-in
voting or uh they do really voting they
do have mail-in and early voting
Republicans don't do that so maybe the
answer is Republicans need to go and you
know vote by mail or vote early now that
way they can make it to DC and you know
support both but I was saying but what I
was saying before is Republicans don't
care about I'm sorry Trump supporters
don't care about their Republicans these
politicians that right there and
definitely when we talk about Legacy and
this is why I don't understand I know
Luke you kind of mentioned it about
Trump not doing himself any favors and
this is why I had been saying on TV and
everything like dude even if you're
going to why not go out gun to Blazing
right but why not go out guns and Blaze
we talked about the importance and and
all of that like why figuratively right
yes like like set it set it on fire like
let loose like
in a video game video game like let
loose though like why why not and he
doesn't do he doesn't do himself any
favors and I don't I don't know if even
Trump understands his own supporters
because they don't care about that stuff
they don't care about Legacy they don't
care about you know being prissy or
being doing things the way that they've
always been done that's not any the fact
that they were attracted to them is
indicative in that is that they don't
care about that stuff so I don't even
understand like what he's doing on his
way out like why he's not like all right
man I'm putting everything on the table
why not he needs to see it
he did see it uh so I I was thinking
about this Trump's sitting in you know
is is Trump willing to go that you know
insane mile martial law Insurrection act
or whatever is he willing to go that far
and I'm like
if if he sees tweets he's probably like
okay but if he sees Republicans turning
on him then he's probably like how much
support do I really have yeah if on
January 6 10 million people really do
show up Trump's gonna be like release
the hounds yeah he's going to open the
gate and just be like we're doing it but
another factor is he's disenfranchising
a lot of his base that was there because
of the promises that he made he promised
to cut spending he promised to get us
out of Wars he promised us all of these
wonderful amazing things he has an
opportunity to put pen to paper and to
make them happen and he's not doing it
he called this bill a disgrace he said
this bill quote is a disgrace demanding
it to be changed immediately and then
what happened signed it right away and
then and again but listen we had super
majorities approving it was that the
case in this particular instance yes
only only 56 people in the uh in the
house voted against it and I think only
eight people in the Senate and yes that
overrides avito oh so Trump look the re
the reality is not that Trump said haha
I'm going to say something and then just
give in no Trump Was Defeated that's it
he can say what he wants to say but if
he doesn't have the power because the
senate in the house over just then stop
playing the game that's what I'm saying
like why not your main principal exactly
in that aspect if you're gonna lose
anyway what do you have to gain don't
sign it exactly don't put your name
exactly we might as well go out like
that look I tried like this was a
disgrace it has all all of this this and
that in it like why not go out like that
he he did get he he redlined right he
yeah but you're giving her any leverage
you have by signing it no no listen if
Trump didn't sign it veto proof majority
it would have been passed through so
Trump I guess to save face was like
here's the red line
right it's the ugly face the idea is and
stop making me defend the guy
the idea is he's gonna be like I approve
the stimulus for the American people I
wouldn't leave him hanging and I object
to these things that everyone else hates
too if he didn't sign it then this look
I'm not saying he made the right move
I'm saying that's I get it that's the
idea
I get that 100 but it's it's look you
don't need to I don't think you need to
drag on Trump for this one as though
it's a failure a failure on his part he
lost like yeah whether he should have
signed it I did should have signed it or
did but that's not what he lost that's
what makes it worse to me it's like it's
like you you took an L but you didn't
take an L like with principle like it's
one thing for me if you get punched like
if you go into a fight a fist fight like
a man I don't care if it's against
whoever Conor McGregor you you're gonna
hold an L regardless look you went out
there and you threw your hands you think
you gave it your best shot but you know
you're talking all this noise about
what's in this bill what's uh uh and
it's calling it a disgrace and then to
support it like I don't know whose face
that he's saving it for because it's not
like the leftists are gonna like him for
it for doing better
but he's telling us pretty nothings like
we're gonna Redline this we're going to
give you the two guys I mean he's
telling us bull crap you just be honest
with us and the Democrats are slapping
him down saying no you're not going to
get what you want here's what I'm saying
I'll tell you my my thoughts on this
signing it and redlining was the worst
thing he could have done for one reason
he basically said I'm mad about this and
I have absolutely no power and the only
thing I can and I'm willing to do is beg
the Democrats to at least do me a favor
it's the same move like Alexandria
ocasio-cortez that came out and said
it's a 5 000 page bill I couldn't read
it yes I'm gonna vote for it you know
what are you doing in Trump's defense
he's the guy that said it should be two
thousand dollars to people not six
hundred and that's why they're coming
quicker yeah let's crash it quicker AOC
said yeah I agree with Trump and then
then now I see they put an amendment to
make it two grand now so that was
because they did pass that yeah yeah so
so the house did pass the two thousand
dollar checks Bill dozens of Republicans
have got behind Donald Trump there so a
lot of people think Mitch McConnell is
going to say no and it's not going to
happen but they're basically telling
Trump now they approved this because
this is what's really really amazing
about this bill not only did Trump come
out and complain about it but he he
actually attacked the establishment from
the left he came from their Left Flank
print more money give more money to the
American people like you I'm the bird on
the vert like Rand Paul said when I just
do twenty thousand dollars why not just
do you know monthly Ubi and just
guaranteed income Trump came from the
left and the funny thing is a lot of
these things that were in the Omnibus
were things he was requesting and
negotiating for so Trump has been you
know it's really funny Michael Tracy has
this really great tweet he's a
journalist I don't know if you've got
you guys find who he is and he said
constant investigations you know a bonk
impeachment all of this stuff and
they're still half the country convinced
we narrowly avoided a fascistic dictator
like Trump was ever that and I keep
telling people Trump tried really really
hard to get things done and couldn't he
hired bad people a lot of the a lot of
people he hired turned on like the
easiest one is Bolton obviously and he
was obstructed every step of the way the
Republicans certainly hated him the
whole time and just used them to get
their judges and their tax breaks and
then when Trump wanted to do things
where are they they're not there for him
like he's been complaining about 230
Trump supporters have been complaining
about 2 30. nothing's gotten done not
one of these people now I mean Ted Cruz
and Josh Hawley have complained about it
a bit so okay I guess but in the end the
Republican establishment is just like a
do-nothing party that just Waits and go
like here's how imagine Republicans
they're like sitting there watching
Democrats just mess everything up and
they go no way don't I'm fighting for
you you know vote for me and they just
sit there and then Democrats go about
mucking things up and you don't do
anything about it so now here we are the
the we are I'll tell you what's really
amazing about all this
you know this kind of spending Bill
happens all the time here's my here's
this really great tweet that's been
going around from Rand Paul this is from
December 23 2018 he said
uh actually let me read the Tweet before
for context he says of course instead of
fixing waste like this and reforming
government the Geniuses in Congress
decided to have a fight over how much
more money they were going to spend AKA
borrow from China speaking of which
buried in the foreign aid reports last
year so that would be set 2017. I
discovered something we give foreign aid
to China so government is so dumb it is
literally borrowing money from China to
give it back to China while paying
interest on it Rand Paul Bravo yep so by
the way he also just released a full
list of all the incredibly dumb things
that the government is spending money on
um I mean if I could just read something
well I'll drop my point up real quick I
kind of lost my train of thought though
but uh Ryan Paul what I was going to say
is people don't pay attention to this
stuff and this year the Democrats tried
everything in their power to get as many
people politically active as possible
and then all of a sudden when this
Omnibus spending package drops no no
more people who people like who
regularly ignore this are now looking at
it going wait what and then I so what
Trump supporters are saying and keep in
mind they'll defend like the hardcore
Trump supporters will defend them no
matter what no matter what he does
they're saying Trump redlining this
highlights it and then forces Congress
to say we approve of the things the
American people don't so sure maybe now
people might be aware of it I think
that's actually what's happening and
it'll be really interesting to see it at
when when America has been brought to
its knees with an economic crisis
they're now saying China's on track to
to overcome overtake America's economy
in only you know seven years or so
accelerating because we've been shut
down and completely obliterated by this
at a time when we're at our worst and
people are desperate 12 million people
facing eviction benefits are going up in
flames and they're blaming Trump I'm
asking why did we just give 10 million
dollars to Pakistani gender studies a
lot of people are asking that even
people on the left are like I don't know
man maybe we should give that money to
people in Flint who need water we're not
spending money on ourselves when we're
broke yeah that's crazy it's not just
that Tim it's the government is
literally spending money to study if
human beings will eat bugs that's one of
their initiatives another one but hold
on another one is to quote invent smart
toilets let me keep going let me just
let me wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait no no I gotta say
that
you mean to tell me I could apply for a
grant and they'll give me money to just
make a toilet with like computers in it
smart toilets yes really but what does a
smart toilet do I don't I don't have any
research when I worked for vice they had
a vice the vice building they had one of
those fancy Japanese toilets yes where I
got a blow dryer in it and stuff is that
we're talking about let's party talking
I want to continue with this all right
with this list
I mean if I had to allocate tax dollars
somewhere but give me a good toilet
there was 8.6 billion dollars spent on
anti-drug efforts in Afghanistan of all
places
isn't that where like 92 of poppy comes
from yes I I had you know a military vet
that came over and all of them were like
yeah we were just there guarding the
Opium Fields yeah for mass production
for the world to have heroin uh there's
money going into Kenyan art classes
there's money going into Afghani and
Pakistani how much book clubs I got to
look it up to tell you uh exactly uh
that there's tens of millions of dollars
going to towards stopping truancy in
schools in the Philippines there's also
speed boats in Sri Lanka and uh study on
lizards and how they walk on treadmills
for 1.5 million dollars yeah so as you
are literally told you can't work as you
are literally kicked out of your
apartment as you're told to pay up in
the taxes in the highest amounts as
they're going to keep going up higher
remember at least lizards are going to
be going on treadmills because of your
tax dollars now the eating bugs thing
how much was that how much money went
into eating I'm gonna have to look up
because look specifically a lot of
itemized it a lot of people point out
things and I'm like there's an argument
there no there is like I don't know if
the government should be spending money
on it but Pakistani gender studies is in
defense there's no defense for that come
on yeah but like researching what humans
are willing to eat could could change
everything yeah it could be useful you
know economy I'm just by spending way
too much money and indebting everyone
that's a good point and there's
hyperinflation yeah people are going to
need to figure out how to eat bugs
exactly that's what I'm saying that's
what I'm saying thanks for checking out
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8pm so come back to check us
out when we go live don't forget to
subscribe hit the like button hit the
notification Bell and we are also
available on all podcast platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all next time